[Musique]
à la saint valentin la fête des amoureux
chaque 14 février c'est la même chose
bien sûr il ya ceux qui aiment la
célébrer on a mon voile n'est pas là
mais m'envoyait un bouquet de fleurs en
forme de coeur il ya les autres ceux qui
ne veulent pas en entendre parler pire
qui la détestent comme l'ol joue
pas que je m'en fous ramadan je m'en
fous vous êtes amoureux de vos fleurs
c'est blasé de la saint valentin ils
sont quelques-uns à l'est partons à leur
rencontre à travers les archives de la
télé c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
préfabriqués ya une région aussi que
justement là interdite donc peut-être
que je vais déménager là bas difficile
de dresser un portrait précis de ces
réfractaires il y à des célibataires
petite soirée filles voilà une petite
soirée fille peut-être qu'on va trouver
il y en a aussi qui trouve que la saint
valentin c'est trop commercial schenker
qui compte ce n'est pas son pâle bijoux
auquel nous mêmes de slave à la proche
de la date fatidique le 14 février
certains prennent même les devants en
2008 à metz un mouvement anti saint
valentin voit le jour le m as v oui vous
avez bien entendu rien de sérieux
évidemment au programme juste une petite
soirée entre célibataires ou non mais au
fait pourquoi un tel mouvement raison
numéro un c'est la saint valentin ça
peut être ça peut être chaque jour
raison numéro 2
c'est un petit peu aussi une fête un peu
commerciale raison numéro 3
pourquoi pas une anti saint valentin oui
c'est vrai ça mais pourquoi pas
et quand le 14 février tombe le jour
d'un match de foot importants comme psg
real madrid en 2018 ça arrange bien
noblesse et de la saint valentin la
copine aulas sultan le match est
bien sûr libre à vous de célébrer cette
journée ou non mais surtout surtout
n'oubliez pas une chose celle de dire je
t'aime à votre moitié peu importe le
jour
[Musique]